let's stick to the phones we'll go next
to our caller from the 931 area code
who's there from 9 31 9 3 1 are you
there we I heard you breathing when we
turned on foot when we went to you oh
yes hello who's this Oh Terry I'm sorry
what's your neither Kelly and Joanne oh
go ahead join I just want to tell you do
not wait rowdy
don't feel that right in your saying
Joey yeah do your political these I
would die if you couldn't hottie oh if
we quit right or she saying writing I
can't not it
do not quit do not quit oh okay well
Thank You Joanne I appreciate that
there's no politic wit right now thank
you yeah educate me tremendously thank
you so where are you calling from Joanne
please if I may ask really really tiny
so I wouldn't Hancock I still say
instead of in the middle of nowhere
oh okay all right and how are things
going you know yeah unfortunately gotcha
yeah you know that's for sure I mean I
had the billboards man here at the Glen
shops they had buy a billion digital
Hillary are you Seri at vert izing that
I meant to kill Hillary that's a joke
how is that not in sight hey Joanne over
here yes what's the best restaurant in
your town oh my goodness probably
McDonald and when I came into the
restaurant
there's no there's not really
restaurants I'm having a hard time
understanding Joanne thank you a post
office a little doctor's office into it
oh I see okay what's like the best
restaurant nearby and maybe in an
adjacent town probably Red Lobster
oh boy Joey listen I am sincerely sorry
that these are the circumstances that
you find yourself in but I appreciate
the words of encouragement and I hope to
hear from you again oh you will thank
you so much yeah you really appreciate
it Joanne instant classic collar on the
David Pakman show